the international human rights movement
depends on the media to get things done
it's not as if we can just go to court
and sue a government because most of the
places where we work don't have courts
that are functioning so one of the
important tools we use is that of
shaming we essentially shine a spotlight
on a government's human rights abuses
and expose them to the world and that
process of exposure is inherently
embarrassing because nobody wants to be
known as a human rights abusers it's
like being known as a child abuser it's
just something that is never acceptable
even somebody like Saddam Hussein hid
his atrocities he didn't want them no
and so if we can expose those abuses we
can put pressure on governments to
change because they they develop a
serious public relations problem which
can be resolved only by changing their
practices now the press is essential for
all of that today in the the age of the
Internet Human Rights Watch can put our
reports as we do on our website and we
will get you know tens of thousands of
visitors every day who will come and
read them but it is still much more
important for us to be able to put major
articles in in the principal newspapers
around the world to go on TV to go on
radio and to really advertise these
atrocities around the world and that
very visible shaming is what governments
tend to notice they recognize that if
articles about their abuse end up in the
New York Times or The Guardian or limone
Dorell pious or what have you that that
changes global perception of them to
their detriment it makes it harder for
them to have the the prestige summits
that they want with low global leaders
it makes it harder for them to attract
investment it makes it harder for them
to travel around the world and be
respected individuals I mean for many
you know very concrete pragmatic reasons
they don't like it and so in that sense
the press is a critical partner in what
we do it doesn't see itself necessarily
Department
the press it usually is in the business
of just objectively reporting but if we
can make news by exposing abuses that
are not widely known and if we can do it
accurately and carefully and reliably
the press will report on what we do and
and they thus play a role in the shading
process that's absolutely